und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend in allen es gibt einige in der CDU
die haben heute beim ZDF
sommer-interview mit ihrem Parteichef
den eigenen Ohren nicht getraut meint
Friedrich Merz da tatsächlich
erschließen nicht mehr aus dass es auf
kommunaler Ebene zu einer Kooperation
mit der AFD kommen könne ja meint er und
er begründet ist damit dass man dort zu
Entscheidungen kommen müsste er sagt
auch das Verbot der Zusammenarbeit mit
der AFD auf europäischer auf Landes und
auf Bundesebene bleibe bestehen nicht
nur aus der SPD kommt jetzt die Frage
bröckelt da eine Brandmauer
wohin will Friedrich Merz und mit wem
wie nie hier schon berichtet
Friedrich Merz steht unter Druck seine
eigene Partei hatte er kürzlich zur
Alternative für Deutschland mit Substanz
erklärt im zdf-sommer-interview versucht
er diese Wortwahl wegzulächeln er hatte
dafür auch in der Union ordentlich
Kritik kassiert wir sind größte
Oppositionsfraktion im Deutschen
Bundestag damit sind wir die Alternative
gegen diese Bundesregierung und wir
müssen Konzepte liefern Vertrauen
gewinnen auch zurückgewinnen und das ist
ein schwieriger Weg ich habe mir nie
Illusionen darüber gemacht wie schwierig
der Weg ist und wir sind jetzt seit
anderthalb Jahren ganz gut unterwegs
aber wir müssen noch zulegen die CDU ist
seit über einem Jahr eingemauert bei 26
27% bis auf april als die Ampel begann
schlimm zu streiten aber davon
profitiert die CDU nicht als profitiert
die AFD bislang galt in der CDU eine
Brandauer in Thüringen wo im nächsten
Jahr gewählt wird mehren sich Stimmen
wie die von Martina schweinsburg
Landrätin seit 1994 für die CDU
Brandmauer hier nicht ehrlich gesagt das
war von Anfang an im polit-sprech der
sicher auf der Bundesebene und auf der
Landesebene durchzuhalten ist auch gibt
es einzelne in der AFD mit denen man
vernünftig zusammenarbeiten kann warum
nicht ich arbeite mit Menschen und nicht
mit Parteien mit der AFD
zusammenarbeiten März müsste seiner
Parteikollegin ein Ausschlussverfahren
verordnen für diese Aussage hat er
zumindest allen angedroht als er
parteiche wurde heute hat auch seine
Brandmauer Löcher zumindest kommunal auf
der kommunalen Ebene ist die
parteipolisierung ohnehin ein bisschen
zu weit vorangeschritten es ist jetzt in
Thüringen ein Landrat gewählt worden und
natürlich ist das eine demokratische
Wahl es ist in Sachsen-Anhalt ein in
einer kleinen Gemeinde einen
Bürgermeister gewählt worden in der AFD
gehört natürlich ist das eine
demokratische Wahl das haben wir doch zu
akzeptieren und natürlich muss in den
Kommunalparlamenten dann auch nach Wegen
gesucht werden wie man gemeinsam die
Stadt das Land den Landkreis bedeutet
März sagt auch er könne verstehen wenn
Menschen sich am Begriff Brandmauer
stören würden den Begriff hat auch
Andreas Rödder in Frage gestellt Leiter
eines konservativen Think Tanks und der
CDU Grundwerte Kommission der Begriff
der Brandmauer ist ein ziemlich
unsouveräner ja er ist ja ein panischer
Begriff denn er tut so als sei hinter
der Brandmauer der Feuersturm und nur
noch verbrannte Erde und ich glaube dass
wir hier eine Form von uns Souveränität
kommunizieren wo kühler Kopf not täte um
mit den politischen Problemen in unserer
Öffentlichkeit umzugehen in der CDU gibt
es einen unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss mit
der AFD keine Zusammenarbeit wieder in
direkter noch in indirekter Form die
Gremien hatten diesen Beschluss 2019
nach dem Mord an Walter Lübcke
bekräftigt für manche hat Friedrich Merz
mit diesem Sommer Interview die
Koordinaten der CDU verrückt rhetorisch
wie inhaltlich und nicht jede und jeder
in der CDU wird das so stehen lassen
so viel ist heute Abend schon klar
wenn die Wähler mit den Stimmzetteln
Fächern um sich ein bisschen Abkühlung
zu verschaffen in der Warteschlange vor
dem Wahllokal dann sagt das etwas über
die Temperaturen in Spanien klar es sagt
auch etwas über diese Parlamentswahl
heute und das große Interesse daran
Machtwechsel Rechtsruck
Richtungsentscheidung all die
Schlagwörter stehen im Raum
Regierungschef Pedro Sanchez droht die
Abwahl seine politischen Gegner haben
versucht seine Politik als sanchismo zu
brandmarken ob das aufgeht und welche
Rolle die Rechtspopulisten jetzt auch
landesweit in Spanien spielen werden wir
heute Abend sehen hier ist einer
wassberg
es ist heiß an diesem Wahlsonntag in
Madrid und die meisten war Lokale sind
nicht klimatisiert mitten in den
Sommerferien
wer hier nicht schwitzen wollte hat
schon vorher seine Stimme zur Post
gegeben 2,5 Millionen eine Rekordzahl am
Brief Fehlern in Spanien
das Recht auf Gesundheit und die
sozialen Rechte im allgemeinen das ist
für mich das Wichtigste
für mich ist das Wichtigste das Spanien
im Mittelpunkt steht und Sanchez geht
er hat uns vom ersten bis zum letzten
Tag gelogen bis hin zu der Kampagne die
dieser Mann jetzt geführt hat
dieser Mann Petrus Sanchez hatte vor der
letzten Wahl versprochen nicht mit
katalanischen Separatisten und Basten
zusammen zu arbeiten es dann aber doch
immer wieder getan seine Stimme gibt der
Sozialdemokratie direkt am Morgen ab
sagt er habe ein gutes Gefühl und
spricht dann zu den auffallen vielen
internationalen Kamerateams den
regelrecht bedrängen
und das bedeutet dass der heutige Tag
sehr wichtig sein wird natürlich für uns
aber auch für die Welt und für Europa
und ich denke das sollte uns auch zum
Nachdenken anregen die letzten Tage hat
Sanchez immer wieder betont wie gut
Spanien vor allem wirtschaftlich unter
seiner Regierung da stand und er hat
öffentlich versucht die Angst zu einem
möglichen Rechtsruck zu schüren in
einigen autonomen Regionen Spaniens
regieren die Konservativen PP bereits
mit den extremen Rechten zusammen und
Alberto fercho der Chef der Partido
Popular hat bis zuletzt nichts dazu
gesagt ob er mit rechts außen auch auf
nationaler Ebene eine Koalition eingehen
würde nach seiner Stimmabgabe am Mittag
gibt er sich schon mal siegessicher
was wir wissen ist dass ab 23 Uhr heute
Abend wenn die Wahlergebnisse bekannt
werden eine neue Ära für Spanien
beginnen kann
es geht um eine Richtungsentscheidung
für das Land kurzverschließung der
Wahllokale lag die Beteiligung bei rund
53 Prozent das ist weniger als 2019
Brief Fehler sind da aber noch nicht
mitgezählt
es gibt in Spanien keine Hochrechnungen
wie bei uns aber es gibt jetzt Ergebnis
Trends die ersten Ergebnisse laufen ein
passend zum Land später am Abend als bei
uns Personen das sind die regierenden
Sozialisten Pep das sind die
Konservativen Herausforderer Thomas
Walde ist unser Korrespondent und Abend
Thomas in Madrid vor dem Parlament wie
sieht denn die Lage jetzt ganz aktuell
aus
also derzeit ist etwas mehr als die
Hälfte der Stimmen tatsächlich
ausgezählt und diese Ergebnisse sind
bekanntgegeben worden das dauert in
diesem Jahr etwas länger als die
vergangen bei den vergangenen Wahlen
weil es mehr Briefwähler gibt weil in
der Urlaubssaison gewählt wird und
daneben gibt es einen zweiten
Anhaltspunkt und das ist eine Prognose
des spanischen Fernsehens beruhigend auf
Umfragen der vergangenen Tage die in den
vergangenen Jahren bei vergangenen
Wahlen immer relativ gut gelegen hat
beides zusammen ergibt folgendes Bild
die konservative Volkspartei die PP
liegt deutlich zu liegt vorne vor den
Sozialisten von Petrus Sanchez die
leicht verlieren ebenso wie dessen
linker Koalitionspartner der auch leicht
verliert als Nummer vier geht durchs
Ziel und verliert deutlich die
rechtsextreme VOX woran liegt das bei
der vergangenen Wahl hat VOX sehr stark
zugelegt damals gab es ein Sondereffekt
durch den Separatismus die Unruhen in
Katalonien diesen Effekt gibt es diesmal
nicht die Region alparteien davon gibt
es mehrere die sind ebenfalls wieder im
parlamentrecht kräftig vertreten aus
Katalonien im Baskenland beispielsweise
kann man Thomas schon sagen was das dann
ganz konkret für die Regierungsbildung
bedeutet
also entscheidend ist am Ende wer hier
im Parlament eine Mehrheit der
Abgeordneten hinter sich versammeln kann
das ist ganz ähnlich wie in Deutschland
nach dem derzeitigen Stand und wie
gesagt es ist sehr mit Vorsicht zu
genießen ist es möglich aber bei weitem
nicht sicher das PP und VOX zusammen
eine Koalition bilden könnten Box hatte
ja angekündigt man sei bereit Alberto
News zum Regierungschef zu machen gegen
politische Konzessionen und die PP hatte
das zumindest nicht ausgeschlossen also
hier gibt es überhaupt keine Brandmauer
die Sozialisten hätten mehrere
Koalitionspartner tatsächlich zur
Verfügung der als die PP das hätte denn
eine Regierung mit Beteiligung der
extremen Rechten könnte nicht auf
Stimmen der Regionalparteien zählen das
heißt für Sanchez würde es schwieriger
werden gänzlich ausgeschlossen ist es
nicht es gibt eine politische
Verschiebung nach rechts Obst für eine
Regierungsmehrheit reicht ist zur Stunde
nicht absehbar Thomas ganz kurz noch wir
hören sprechöre im Hintergrund was ist
da los vor dem Parlament im Moment
das gibt ein paar Demonstranten hier das
sind Nichtwähler die sich Gehör
verschaffen die sich hier verschaffen
aber nicht an der Wahlurne das ein
bisschen widersprüchlich wenn man so
will das ist aber wirklich eine kleine
Mehrheit muss Minderheit muss man sagen
es wird wieder gerechnet mit einer
Wahlbeteiligung trotz der Hitze trotz
der Sommerzeit ähnlich hoch wie beim
vergangenen mal mit rund 70%, dass ich
das nicht groß verändert also das was
man da hört ist eine wirklich kleine
sehr laute Minderheit okay klingt lauter
als es ist Thomas Walter ZDF Madrid
herzlichen Dank für diese ganze
aktuellen Informationen Spanien ist für
viele Deutsche ja Urlaubsziel und
manchmal zweite Heimat seine Politik
bekommt verglichen damit überraschend
wenig Aufmerksamkeit das werden wir
jetzt ändern mit Günther maihold
Politikwissenschaftler Fachgebiet
Spanien und Lateinamerika an der FU
Berlin Herr Professor schönen guten
Abend guten Abend sie haben gerade mit
angehört was unser Körper sagt was sagt
Ihnen dieser Trend heute Abend über die
politischen Machtverhältnisse in Spanien
nun wir sehen zum einen dass die beiden
Großparteien doch wieder an
Unterstützung gewinnen auf Kosten ihrer
kleineren möglichen Koalitionspartner
dass es ein anderer Trend als wir den
vorher hatten als die beiden
Großparteien massive Verluste hinnehmen
mussten das heißt es wird immer
schwieriger werden sich Mehrheiten noch
zusammen zu glauben und das wird
bestimmt auch für einen möglichen
Regierungschef der Volkspartei so sein
er wird wahrscheinlich nicht darum
hinkommen auch mit Regionalparteien
Vereinbarungen abschließen zu müssen
jetzt ist es ja so dass der aktuelle
Regierungschef extra die Wahlen
vorgezogen hatte weil er sich davon
Erfolg versprochen hat und wenn man mal
zum Beispiel auf die Wirtschaftszahlen
guckt dann sehen die ganz gut aus die
Inflation in Spanien aktuell bei 1,6
Prozent das ist niedrig im Vergleich die
Wirtschaft wächst was ist denn Sanchez
Problem gewesen dass er damit nicht
einfach durchmarschieren konnte und eine
neue Amtszeit bekam
seine politische Agenda hat sich im
Wahlkampf nicht verkauft sondern es ist
sehr viel mehr in Erinnerung geblieben
die ewigen Streitigkeiten in seiner
Regierung es sind sehr viele Elemente
seiner Regierungsprogramms in den
Vordergrund gerückt worden die stark auf
Minderheiten bezogen sind es ist dem
verübelt worden dass er die
Zusammenarbeit mit den Regionalparteien
in Katalonien und in das Baskenland
gesucht hat all dies hat zu einer
gewissen Erschöpfung der Bevölkerung
gegenüber der regierenden Partei
beigetragen jetzt haben die
Konservativen Wahlkampf angekündigt dass
sie gleich Dutzende Gesetze aus der
sanchez-zeit wieder zurücknehmen werden
sollten Sie tatsächlich an die Macht
kommen tobt da in Spanien auch sowas wie
ein Kulturkampf
in gewisser Hinsicht schauen es ist eine
extreme Polarisierung in der
Gesellschaft aber natürlich auch ein
politischen Feld vorhanden und es muss
mit dieser Rückabwicklung gerechnet
werden von vielen Gesetzen und das
bedeutet natürlich auch dass alte
politische Gräben wieder aufgerissen
werden dass es zu keiner Versöhnung auch
nicht bezogen auf die nationale Einheit
kommen wird weil die Separatisten in
Anführungszeichen sich ausgeschlossen
fühlen als es ist kein
Konsens in der Gesellschaft vorhanden
und es gibt eben auch nicht diesen
grundlegenden politischen Konsens lassen
sie uns Herr Professor bitte noch über
VOX reden die
Rechtspopulisten die äußerst rechten
stehen im Zentrum des Interesses über
dieser Wahl einfach auch deshalb weil
erstmal seit dem Tod von Diktator Franco
und der war schon 1975 wieder eine
Partei aus dem äußerst rechten Spektrum
Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen
könnte jetzt sehen wir allerdings in den
aktuellen Zahlen das Vox im Vergleich
zur Wahl davor doch stark abgestürzt ist
heißt das viele Spanierinnen und Spanier
haben dann doch gesagt das wollen wir
dann nicht nun die Volkspartei hat
besonderen Wahlkampf gemacht um auch VOX
zu schwächen und damit der Partei keine
so große Mitsprache bei der zukünftigen
Regierungsführung einzuräumen jetzt
haben wir die paradoxe Situation dass
die Partei massiv verloren hat aber
gleichzeitig an politischen Gewicht
wahrscheinlich gewinnen wird und das ist
eine besondere Herausforderung wenn man
an zahle zahlreiche politische Punkte in
ihrer Programmatik sich ansieht die eben
massiv nach hinten gerichtet sind die
eben nicht den Konsens sondern eher die
Auseinandersetzung wieder neu anstacheln
sagen Sie mal kurz zwei von zwei drei
Punkte die sie da im Blick haben bitte
nun ein Thema ist die Umgang mit den
Autonomie Regierungen der zweite Punkt
ist Migration als zentrale Achse der
Bestimmung nationale Einheit und zum
kann dann eben auch die der Schwerpunkt
die nationale severinität gegenüber
Europa bewahren zu wollen die Partei ist
besonders Europa kritisch jetzt haben
wir ja gesehen in mehreren Ländern
gleich in Europa einen Rechtsruck in der
Vergangenheit also Finnland fällt einem
ein Schweden Italien
mal angenommen es würde diesen
Rechtsruck tatsächlich jetzt auch in
Spanien geben was hat Europa dann in
Zukunft aus Madrid zu erwarten und wir
sehen das jetzt im drittgrößten Land
Italien und dem viertgrößten Land der EU
Spanien sich die Kompass Konstellation
verschoben hat das bedeutet auch eine
Veränderung in der politischen Agenda
für die Europäische Union und es wird
sehr viel schwieriger werden hier
Konsens zu finden es wird sehr viel mehr
Widerspruch geben und es wird eine
Betonung politischer Themen wie etwa der
Migrationsfrage wie auch der nationale
Souveränität geben die das
Zusammenwirken in Europa erwerben dürfen
ganz kurz vielleicht in einem Satz wie
lange wird es ungefähr dauern bis wir
tatsächlich Klarheit haben und nur
Koalition dann steht in Madrid das kann
einige Monate dauern es ist immer
schwierig im Madrid sich zusammen zu
finden und insofern sollten wir Geduld
haben Günter Maiwald war das
Politikwissenschaftler von der FU Berlin
Herr Professor vielen Dank für ihre
Expertise heute Abend live aus Berlin
danke schön
die Situation in Israel ist dermaßen
aufgewühlt dass sie die Armee erreicht
und damit eine der Säulen des Staates
und gewissermaßen seine
Lebensversicherung Hannah damit beginnst
du jetzt den Nachrichtenüberblick
begleitet von zahlreichen Protesten hat
das israelische Parlament heute den
abschließenden Beratungen über ein
Kernelement der umstrittenen
Justizreform begonnen bereits morgen
könnten die finalen Abstimmungen dazu
stattfinden und zuvor noch einen
Kompromiss zwischen Regierung und
Opposition zu erzielen besuchte
Staatschef Herzog am Abend
Regierungschefs mit dann Yahoo im
Krankenhaus nachdem diesen in der Nacht
ein Herzschrittmacher eingesetzt worden
war in Jerusalem demonstrierten
unterdessen 10.000 begegner der Reform
gestern kündigten zudem 10.000
Reservisten an sich nicht mehr zum
Dienst zu melden wenn das Vorhaben
beschlossen werden sollte auch
zahlreiche Befürworter des justizumbaus
ging heute auf die Straße wie hier im
tellerief
im sächsischen Sebnitz haben vier teils
maskierte Personen eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft attackiert der
Staatsschutz der Dresdner Polizei
ermittelt wegen gefährlicher
Körperverletzung Beleidigung und
Hausfriedensbruch nach ersten
Erkenntnissen der Polizei sollen sich
die vier Männer über eine Hintertür
Zutritt zu dem Haus verschafft und zwei
Bewohner angegriffen haben dabei hätten
sie rassistische Parolen gerufen die
Angreifer konnten fliehen einen
18-Jähriger Afghane musste ambulant
versorgt werden
wer nach mindestens 45 Beitragsjahren in
den Ruhestand geht der erhält in
Deutschland im Durchschnitt
1.543 Euro Rente im Monat das hat das
Bundesarbeitsministerium auf Anfrage von
Linken Fraktionschef Bartsch erklärt die
Angaben beziehen sich auf das Ende des
vergangenen Jahres deutliche
Unterschiede gibt es zwischen Männern
und Frauen Rentnerinnen kommen im
Schnitt auf
1323 Euro das sind gut 300 Euro weniger
als Rentner
Urlaub sollte Erholungs sein
unbeschwerte Zeit auf der griechischen
Ferieninsel Rhodos ist das Gegenteil der
Fall dass Flammenmeer eines Waldbrandes
außer Kontrolle zwingt Urlauber und
Bewohner zur Flucht und zwar fast 20.000
von ihnen die größte Evakuierungsaktion
die es je bei Waldbränden in
Griechenland gegeben hat die Behörden
suchen Matratzen und Bettdecken für
Notunterkünfte es gibt wie immer in
diesem wunderbaren Land bei den Menschen
auch eine beeindruckende Welle der
Hilfsbereitschaft dennoch haben mehrere
Reiseveranstalter ihre Flüge nach Rhodos
erstmal ausgesetzt für halb Griechenland
gilt die Warnung vor extremer
Waldbrandgefahr bei Temperaturen bis zu
45 Grad Andreas Postel jetzt mit den
Bildern
nur noch raus aus dem brennenden
Paradies auf dem Flughafen von Rhodos
zum Teil chaotische Szenen tausende
Touristen warten auf einen Heimflug
manche nur mit dem wenigen was sie
hektisch zusammenpacken konnten als die
Flammen kamen
und zwar Mitternacht vom Feueralarm
aufgeschreckt dann wurde das Hotel
evakuiert und jetzt warten wir hier
hatte Glück bekommt ihren Heimflug und
landet in Stuttgart
jeder kann ziemlich schnell ziemlich nah
und ja man ist schon ein bisschen
mulmiges Gefühl aber
also das Hotel hat sich dann schon
bemüht auch das schnell die am Wasser
verteilt haben gesagt wie es weitergeht
weil die Reiseleiter waren ja auch nicht
erreichbar das Internet es gab keinen
Strom wechselnde Winde treiben die
Flammen auch Richtung Hotelanlagen in
Kiotari Familie Stein mit ihren zwei
kleinen Kindern wird aufgefordert zum
Strand zu laufen
wir müssen unser ganzes Gepäck
zurücklassen weil direkt der Notfall
Alarm halt ausgelöst worden ist dass ein
Feuer also Feueralarm aber und in
dementsprechend sind halt direkt
geflüchtet ne an den Strand sie nehmen
nur die wichtigsten Dinge mit an ihrem
letzten Urlaubstag kommen sie sogar mit
dem regulären Rückflug nach Frankfurt
zurück und mit dem Schrecken davon
19000 Menschen werden offiziellen
Angaben zufolge aus 12 Dörfern und
sämtlichen Hotels in den betroffenen
Regionen der Insel in Sicherheit
gebracht nachdem die Brände dort außer
Kontrolle geraten waren
dies ist die größte Evakuierungsaktion
zur Sicherheit für Einwohner und
Touristen die jemals in unserem Land
durchgeführt wurde
Touristen aus aller Welt verbringen die
Nacht in Notunterkünften Turnhallen
einige auch im Freien viele berichten
uns von einer großen Welle griechischer
Hilfsbereitschaft Einheimische auf der
nicht betroffenen Inselseite bieten
private Unterkünfte an besorgen Essen
Wasser und Matratzen es brennt längst
nicht auf ganz raus aber die Feuer die
es gibt sind offenbar schwer und der
Kontrolle zu bringen die hohen
Temperaturen und starke Winde erschweren
die Löscharbeiten das Außergewöhnliche
an dieser Hitzewelle in Griechenland sei
aber die lange dauert meteorologen
sprechen von einer so noch nie da
gewesenen Situation und fordern ein
besseres Krisenmanagement
das fängt beim Brandschutz an sowohl was
die Entfernung von brennbaren Material
angeht wie auch die rechtzeitige Warnung
damit wir ein besseres Bild der
Gefährdung haben und das wird beim
professionellen lösch-einsatz auf der
Zivilschutz waren für weite Teile
Griechenlands vor extrem hohe Waldbrand
Gefahren im griechischen Urlaubsparadies
gilt weiterhin die höchste Alarmstufe
der Forschungsleiter des nationalen
Wetter Observatoriums in Athen sagt wir
werden wahrscheinlich eine Hitzewelle
von 16 oder 17 Tagen erleben die es in
unserem Land noch nie zuvor gegeben hat
das ist die Kathedrale von Odessa sie
wurde von Katharina der Großen gegründet
von Stalin gesprengt von der Ukraine
wieder aufgebaut und vom russischen
Patriarchen Kyrill dem ersten geweiht
demselben Kyrill der heute ein glühender
Verehrer von Präsident Putin ist
demselben Putin dessen Raketen
vergangenen Nacht das Weltkulturerbe
Odessa ins visiernamen eingeschoss traf
die Kathedrale und hat sie schwer
beschädigt ein Gotteshaus und der ganze
Wahnsinn dieses Krieges daran Hassan
seitdem ist in Odessa
es ist ein Stich mitten ins Herz von
Odessa vollzogen durch einen russischen
Marschflugkörper seit Sonntagmorgen
strömen Menschen zu ihrer Kathedrale und
sie alle kennen deren Geschichte viele
Bürger helfen wo sie können und sei es
mit bloßen Händen aber auch Anteilnahme
kann die Arbeit von Rettungskräften
erschweren
[Musik]
bitte treten Sie zurück es ist
gefährlich vorhin sind Teile von der
Decke gestürzt und eine Frau stand nur
fünf Meter entfernt machen Sie Platz
nach Stunden ist die Decke der
Kathedrale gesichert ist der größte
Schutz beseitigt es bleibt der Stau
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll wie
ich es ausdrücken kann das ist alles
sehr Angst ein flößend wir versuchen zu
lächeln so wie alles ist gut aber es ist
erschreckend wir wollen unser Leben
leben so wie es zuvor war
seit Tagen beschießt die russische Armee
und deshalb mit Raketen in Wellen
flankiert von drohnengeschwadern
die sind wehrlos gegen diese
Marschflugkörper diese Raketen haben
einen großen Nachteil ihre Fehlerrate
beim Einschlag beträgt 5 bis 600 Meter
sie sind äußerst ungenau ich wäre nicht
überrascht wenn das Ziel tatsächlich der
Hafen von Odessa gewesen wäre sie
versuchten zu treffen aber ihre Raketen
schießen irgendwo hin
Priester in ihrem zerschossenen
Gotteshaus sie gehören der
russisch-orthodoxen Kirche in der
Ukraine an mangelnde Distanz zu Moskaus
Patriarchat das den Krieg gut heißt wird
ihnen vorgeworfen ein Priester
widerspricht
wir haben diesen Krieg vom ersten Tag
verurteilt wir haben keine Verbindung
nach Moskau man sieht Moskau zerstört
unsere Kirchen diese Rakete landete in
unserer Kathedrale
Religion Architektur und Kultur
Odessa hat viele alte Verbindungen nach
Russland lange hofften die Menschen hier
dies könnte ihre Stadt schützen
ein Krieg der nichts und niemanden
verschont
jetzt aber du Hannah mit was ganz
anderes ja und zwar mit Sport der der
jonas wingertor hat
die die Tour de France gewonnen für den
26-Jährigen ist es bereits der zweite
Gesamtsieg beim schwersten Radrennen der
Welt in der Gorge waren am Ende der Tour
mit einem Vorsprung von mehr als 7
Minuten vor seinem Rivalen today pogata
aus Slowenien
einen Tag vor dem WM-Auftakt der
deutschen
Frauenfußball-Nationalmannschaft gegen
marokko hat Bundestrainerin Forst
Tecklenburg betont dass das Team alles
geben werde um zu gewinnen offen blieb
ob für mehrere angeschlagene
Spielerinnen Einsatzchancen bestehen so
stark Aufstellung gab die
Bundestrainerin keine Details bekannt
anstoß ist morgen um 10:30 Uhr deutscher
Zeit das ZDF überträgt live
bei der Schwimm-WM in Japan hat es heute
zum Start der beckenwettbewerbe eine
weitere Medaille für Deutschland gegeben
Europameister Lukas Mertens gewann
Bronze über 400 Meter Freistil hinter
Australien und Tunesien außerdem vielen
gleich drei Weltrekorde so verbesserte
unter anderem der Franzose Leon machère
über 400 Meter Lagen den letzten
einzelweltrekord von schwimmlegende
Michael Phelps
anstatt in der Kolonne zu bleiben gehe
ich meinen eigenen Weg sagt der
Modedesigner Jean Paul Gaultier schon
immer Punk Einflüsse kegel-bhs Männer in
Hochzeitskleidern 5 jahrzehntelang ging
das so er sagt es auch noch mit 71 und
obwohl er nicht mehr im täglichen
Geschäft ist
Goji hat eine Fashion Freak Show und ist
damit zu Gast in München er will immer
noch Regeln brechen und er kann jetzt
frei sein Alexandra havelin zeigt uns
mehr
er schockiert will die Definition von
Schönheit dehnen
er zerrt am Zeitgeist bricht Tabus denn
was ist schön Jean Paul Gault provoziert
seit mehr als fünf Jahrzehnten
jeder ist für den anderen ein Freak es
gibt nicht die eine Art von Schönheit
sondern viele
man muss nur die Augen öffnen wir sind
so darauf gedrillt zu urteilen das ist
gut dass es nicht gut in Wirklichkeit
kann man Schönheit fast überall erkennen
Schönheit in all ihren Spielarten zeigt
er in seiner fashion Freakshow
ein Potpourri aus Popmusik Tanz und
Kabarett und eine Reise durch Jean Paul
Gaultiers Leben als Designer eine
Renaissance seiner legendären Entwürfe
das rosa Korsett mit spitzen Körbchen
für Madonna Katapult
die Designidee kreiert im Kinderzimmer
[Musik]
mein erstes Modell war mein Teddybär
Nana für ihn habe ich den allerersten
kegel-bh entworfen mit Papier und ein
paar Stecknadeln wurde er zum transbär
zu meiner ersten Hose
mit 24 bringt er seine ersten Skizzen
auf den Laufsteg etabliert sein eigenes
Label
[Musik]
S in allen Formen Männer im Rock als on
for terrible kehrt er dem Mode mean
Stream den Rücken
Diversität das Spiel mit
Geschlechterrollen Nachhaltigkeit für
Jean Paul Gaultier keine Trends sondern
Teil seiner DNA sie treibt den
71-Jährigen bis heute an
reflexione unserer Zeit bei allem was
gerade in der Welt passiert denke ich
brauchen wir den Blick auf das Positive
und die Lebensfreude
er bleibt der der den Blick für
Schönheit immer wieder aufs Neue
herausfordert und das mit einem
Augenzwinkern
und dann gibt es noch diesen sehr
schönen Satz von Jean Paul Gaultier ich
liebe Menschen die einzigartig aussehen
nicht perfekt sondern singulär
schauen wir traditionell jetzt auf das
was uns erwartet in der kommenden Woche
hier ist der heute journal Ausblick von
Oliver Heuchert
[Musik]
Taiwan probt den Ernstfall am Montag
beginnen die jährlichen Militärübungen
Taiwan will vor allem für den Fall einer
Blockade der Insel trainieren in der
Region nehmen die Spannungen seit
Monaten zu
am Dienstag werden die Bayreuther
Festspiele eröffnet mit einem Spätwerk
Richard Wagners den Parsifal neu
inszeniert mit dieser Brille kann ein
Teil der Zuschauer virtuelle Ergänzungen
miterleben wieder Regisseur des
passivball ist hier vorführt
am Donnerstag Tag die Spitze der
europäischen Zentralbank die Erwartungen
eine weitere zinseerhöhung den Inflation
ist nach wie vor hoch am Tag zuvor
trifft die US-Zentralbank ebenfalls
seine Zinsentscheidung
am Freitag kommen die Delegierten der
AFD zu ihrem Bundesparteitag in
Magdeburg zusammen am Samstag schließt
sich die europawahlversammlung der
Partei an hier will die AFD ihr
Verhältnis zur EU klären
Ausblick auf die eher durchwachsenden
Wetteraussichten morgen ist es im Osten
anfangs noch meist freundlich sonst sind
die Wolken dichter und von Westen kommen
Schauer und teils kräftige Gewitter auf
einem lebhaften Südwestwind werden 20
bis 30 Grad erreicht auch in den
nächsten Tagen ist es windig und
regnerisch dazu gibt es eher kühle 15
bis 27 Grad
im Namen all der Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die hinter den Kulissen an
dieser Sendung gearbeitet haben sagen
wir zwei danke für Ihr Interesse und die
nächsten Nachrichten hier gibt es gegen
0 Uhr
[Musik]